Welcome everybody to Stockton Kevin Cutters for another podcast. My guest today is
Brian Measley. He's a very popular and outspoken advocate author researcher with over 20 years
experience and national health. He opposes the widespread perception that life is getting older
to actually be sick and getting a disease and be a disease and instead supports the truth that
in your 40s, 50s, 60s and even the art you could actually have the best years of your life.
So Brian is the founder and host of over talk about the art of anti-aging.com where he's a vast
followers of nearly 500,000 supporters for his mission and it is own words quote we are changing the
very definition of anti-aging to mean you're against all the lies commonly associated with getting older.
Such as that hitting your 40s and beyond means becoming increasingly undesirable
incapable and doomed to suffering and diseases. I love that. So instead so many people have embraced
the art of anti-aging.com because Brian shares a very positive message in terms of your physical
mental and emotional health and well-dead in your middle years and golden years.
There are truly meant to be your best years. Brian as hosting this is we're going to get into and talk
about a worldwide release of his third major online summit and we're going to encourage all of our
listeners to join that. It's called younger, longer, the insiders help summit. It's going to
launch August 11, 2021 and it's going to be just fantastic. Get wait for that. It's a free online
summit features 22 of the most renowned and respected anti-aging and longevity doctors
including all their research. You're going to get a lot of information. So Brian thank you for being
on the podcast today. I have some questions that I think are going to be very pertinent and
I'm going to stop talking about you talk. So first question I'm going to try to lead into this is
you've done so much work in development for the last 20 years in natural health care.
Why did you choose to get into anti-aging? What brought you down this path?
First of all thanks for having me on and hello everybody. I think we're edging on over 25 years now.
So I have to update that. It's been some time now that I've been immersed in all of this
interesting and our pre-conversation brought up Joe Mercola and that was really Joe and I
with nobody knew his name and I'm sure a lot of people now are familiar with his name. Start out
20 some years ago with natural health with him but my story predates all of that. I'm going to try
to give you the short version here. Can you get a little emotional actually? Long story short I'm
51 right now. I cite that because you can roughly say the first half of my life was pretty challenging
in many respects. I grew up in a rough city neighborhood in Chicago lost some friends to gangs.
Even more impacted I guess we'll say is my own father. It was a very good man until my age of around
nine and he turned severely alcoholic and abusive to me and my family and my mother and my sister.
His story reads like a novel that people wouldn't believe. He was a spine world war two. He lost his
a son from a previous marriage. He lost his first wife while they were in an argument and stepped out
of a car and she got hit by this truck. So there were some strategies and in those days you may well know
that people did not embrace dealing with emotional issues in a healthy way. It wasn't going to
counseling or things like that was kind of found upon. He must be a crazy person to do that compared
to today. So he didn't deal in a healthy way things hit the bottle kind of took it out on us as the
short version and it was rough for young young man as well as my sister and mom dealing with that. So
that was another major challenge in life and there were still more and then as I got older he went
through to his credit he did you know go through it and kick the habit but he still retained a lot
of anger and he was still very emotionally abusive from that point forward. I tell this story
because then you know he went through about 10 years of slow death from a really it started to
stand from emphysema but a number of different diseases and we being my mom my sister and I especially
my mother of course we're in and out of the medical system with him for a good decade and I watch
this system we're talking 80s 90s now for the 90s I watched this how inept the system could be.
I saw it from the inside I saw my mom you know fighting basically you the medical system for his
care and I saw this man getting carted around from hospital hospital and and you know basically he
was an ex you know it was just insensitive and and other respects so I saw from the inside long story
shirt thank goodness in a way because he suffered so much he finally did pass away so now is equipped
with you know frankly a lot of anger at what I witnessed inside of that medical system and how
mismanaged his care in so many ways and didn't dwell on some solutions that I was already becoming
aware of the natural you know orientation I'm not opposed you know obviously some prescriptions and
drugs do have their place but even back then the medical system was kind of this model of drugs are
the answer and so I saw that from the inside paired with that and all this roughness that I was going
through in my life I have a lot of internal issues I became a young father in my first marriage
myself and I was so dirt poor I even had to sell a CD collection to keep the heat on another month for
my baby you know so I went through some tough times what saved me and I mean literally saved my
life the reason I'm sitting here today thriving today able to help so many people are powerful women
like my mother like my sister like certain teachers I had actually who stood by in these certain
friends they literally held me up and kept me kept me going in in life when I could have taken some
really dark terrible turns doctors so flash forward several you know multiple years now I was inside
by the way one of the first serious jobs I had was middle management inside of a pharmaceutical
benefits management company I witnessed some things in there that I could not believe happened I
thought it was just you know you know stuff from the other side so to speak was overdoing how
that system works but it's not true when everybody signs up if they do for the free younger
longer health summit that's coming up that you mentioned please watch the video right after you
sign up because I share this terrible joke that I heard inside of the while working from these
executives in this company that just said everything I'm not gonna share more on that taken down a
different path but long story short after women saved my life older women caring women so flash
forward now I started off you know like I said Joe and I and I helped him build that into the you know
monster that it became the good monster I left that I've worked with plenty of other you know doctors
and others throughout the year since then and then you know built this organization and I bring that up
because I saw I saw natural and some alternative solutions truly helping people saving lives
and I saw that they have everything to do with the later years middle and later years of life
indeed being the best years of life and it did not match not only this pervasive message out there
which is that getting older equals becoming undesirable incapable doomed to suffering in disease and
and it's horrible but but look at the media you know if if an alien came down from outer space and watched
our TV shows they would think that 90% of our population is 20 somethings and getting older is
something to laugh about basically I mean that's just this overriding message and that indeed getting
older means you're doing nonsense that that completely contradicted what I was seeing in research
from all these doctors you know like yourself who embrace you know a wider perspective integrated
health natural health and then I watched as my own you know mother and my sister who's older than me
and others these people who saved my life were even impacted by this negative messaging about getting
older and I said wait a minute wait a minute I have multiple paths I can go down here to honor these
people these women who helped me I'm going to share this message that getting older equals actually should
and can equal whether you have diseases whether you suffered through and fought those diseases it can
and ought to equal the best years of your life your 40s 50s 60s 70s even beyond ought to be the best
years of your life that's the medium-length version of the story of why I launched the art of anti-aging
and why you know our mission is basically to help people bypass that negative messaging and most
importantly to provide them the most effective steps to look and feel their best avoid fight disease
what I was always said I mean people said what are you going to retire it's like I think the whole idea
of retirement and then your life just kind of goes downhill because you're no longer productive in
society that really began just in the last century yeah there's no biblical correspondence to the
I don't believe I should ever retire I need to continue to share what God has given me
until I'm taken out of here you know your life should be like a candle and it should go out and you're
done it with your role here and you move on so we've kind of set that society haven't we in the last
hundred years where okay you finished your production your productive years at age 60 or whatever and
now you just quit and you you know you slide downhill and that's that's really a shame what we've
done the wisdom that is in the human race of people in their 70s and 80s that could could change could
continue to change the world that we're losing is very sorrowful so I would agree with you yeah it
to me it's the biggest barrel nonsense frankly that you know you hear this expression sometime hey
move aside it's our turn from younger generations hey I love you know all ages and I and and and what
anybody can bring to the tables a good thing but your time is dome and done when like you said you know
your life is truly over as long as you are alive it's your time it's your time it's your time
you need to still be productive politics business health education no matter what field and in fact
like you said you know it's only in a little bit in my view less than the last hundred years but
throughout eons throughout all of human history you know this age was valued it was it was it was it was
respected in most cultures you know and it ought to be frankly I mean you know and in so many ways in
terms of in terms of you know living your life and feeling good you know I talked to many people who
have embraced you know who have bypassed this notion of getting older equals doom doom doom and they
are living their best years whether that means they're dealing you know with with things that you know
often we're hit with disease cancer or pain you know arthritis underneath that doesn't mean these
can't be your best years and there's a lot you can even deal about those things as we've certainly
shared with folks so what do you see as like the biggest challenges that people face as they get into
their 50s and 60s and be it you know I mean and there's two two path answers I can go down there
and one I won't you know I could talk about this another day but there's certainly you know the
emotional challenges you know that get in our part and parcel you know this is only one aspect of it
that I'm talking about here is a lot of these if you if you're if your mindset if you believe
that getting older equals doom that it means I'm done I'm downhill I'm retired I'm no longer
useful well guess what's gonna happen you're going to become you know sick and not useful I mean
you know our mind is a powerful thing so that's one avenue I have to talk about all day but there's
also a lack of it's just lack of awareness on some mighty on a physical side of things and we can
go down this avenue more so there's some mighty impactful in a negative thing in a negative way
things that we do that we aren't yet as a society aware of we're doing that specifically I have
to do with toxins I mean you know doctors all about you know what we allow into our being what we
allow into our bodies and what we try to keep out and you know I hear a lot of folks say hey I'm eating
really well so I'm not gonna worry about toxins you know because my body I'm doing everything I'm
tend to set my body against it and in a time 100 years ago 200 years ago when we didn't have
this overwhelming amount of toxins pouring into us in my view that would have been okay but now
I say to people listen you could do everything in the world to become the healthiest person possible
by putting all the right foods in and getting your exercise and your proper sleep but there are so
many toxins we're burdened with today a covered emotional we can go down that avenue another day
but in a physical sense and I'll get you know I'll get into one area here that I think people aren't
nearly aware of enough with in regards to personal care products and cosmetics and how impactful this
is but we but there's just this overburdened of toxins today that we could be as healthy as possible but
if we don't take steps to reduce these toxins they're overwhelming it's a it's a tsunami constantly
of toxins we really have to take steps to reduce these in our lives well we are like you said I think
exposed to things I mean how many chemical companies are producing you know new chemical
arrays on a weekly basis to do something to make your deodorant more sticky to your skin or to
you know whatever can be the downside of capitalism here the whatever they can sell more of
um to make more desirable um you know and we buy this stuff because it's simpler it's easier it
smells better it feels better um and we're exposed to things that our ancestors were never exposed to
and our detox pathways are completely overwhelmed we see when we test people for cancer we test
for causes it's it's probably over 80% of the time the cause of the cancer is a toxin that gets
into the cell that disrupts the replication pathways and now the cell goes into rapid replication
which is the definition of cancer so let's let's continue down that pathway if you will where where do
you see the greatest maybe misunderstanding of toxins because again like you said I have patients
that go no are you kidding it couldn't be a toxin I mean I've eaten organic for the last 20 years
well really let me that's a great place for me to say really well the first thing I'm going to say
that everyone listening is then if if if you believe you know that you're eating healthy remember this
anything you will put on your skin you're eating so question that next step go to your bathroom if
that's where you keep your cosmetics and personal care products as most people do turn those labels
around read see if you can decipher what some of those ingredients are in the first place and say are
you really eating healthy are you because you're putting that on your skin would you put that in your
mouth and swallow that product but all of these products here here's a statistic for you a couple
of statistics here in the United well first in the European Union for example they have banned 1,300
plus chemicals from their personal care products and cosmetics here in the United States because
it's a powerful industry only 11 can be banned here's another statistic so are you saying Brian that though
that the 1300 minus 11 all those are still approved still in the US and are being used in the US
yes sir and there are actually thousands more that are under scrutiny from the EU so that number is
going to go higher meanwhile here 11 have been banned I could talk all day also about why this is the case
I'll cover that briefly in a moment because I think a lot of people believe hey we're protected
someone's watching out for us I will say this I've heard and I've seen that in the United States the
most unregulated industry is personal care and cosmetics back in 1938 the FDA really laid down
you know the the last substantial guidelines for the cosmetic personal care industry 1938 nothing's
changed really since then and back then you know what they said self-regulate they hey industry
self you're on your own self-regulate you're on your own well guess what that's turned into a wild west
situation but before I go in a little more depth on that I want everyone to remember this when
you're pushing a grocery cart down the cosmetics and personal care products aisle and a store you
are pushing it down a food aisle remember that if nothing else and treat it the same way that you're
pushing that grocery cart down the produce aisle and everywhere else because again when you put
anti-aging creams typical anti-aging creams typical deodorants under your arm typical anything on
your face that you do if the molecules are small enough they penetrate your skin they penetrate
into your body they can get into your bloodstream and they're sent around all the organs of your body
and guess what these products as you alluded to are designed these ingredients these chemicals these
toxins are designed to be small enough to penetrate that's why they do whatever they do but they're
toxic they these there are five basic classes of these ingredients direct carcinogens cancer-causing
agents known allowed hidden carcinogens and even more scary category because what that means is
go back to your chemistry class from high school when you combine two or more chemicals
many of many of these products contain many chemicals they do what they can create third
chemicals other chemicals in other words they're not even required to test that they don't know
you have the impact of course and that's only one product now if I put you know three different
products on my face we've got all kinds of stuff going on that we don't know well there have been
independent studies and research done and there's plenty of hidden carcinogens that are
offshoot products from this of course there's allergens there's endocrine disrupting ingredients
by one count over 200 were found in in in our typical cosmetic personal care products endocrine
disrupting mean hormone disrupting chemicals and I say this to people there are in many cases I would
actually doctor rather eat by putting on my mouth and and swallowing some of these ingredients
then putting it on my skin why because at least when you eat something through your mouth your body
has a number of mechanisms filters will call them in place you know I mean liver being a you know a
key to try to kick some of those toxins out when you put stuff on your skin there are a few if
any barriers in place this stuff goes there you know if it when it penetrates and gets into the blood
stream there's really not much stopping it from doing well like you said that you do have your gut
barrier you have your blood brain barrier you have your skin barrier but with these chemicals are
designed to cross the skin barrier to help moisten the deeper layers of your skin or whatever that
thing is supposed to do it's in your body them it's in your bloodstream it's if it's in the
subcutaneous tissues it's going to be absorbed into the bloodstream and your liver is going to have
to deal with it you know it's pathways that we speak about your cytochrome P450 pathways
in your liver your one pathway in your liver are already overwhelmed by the pesticides and
herbicides you're exposed to so it circulates around again circulates around again and getting
lodged into your fat cells which have the spiritual gift of accommodation just take those in
and that's a major piece of cancer that's why these are carcinogens and I speak about in my book about
a subject called publication bias so even when these companies say oh we have these studies that
prove that it's safe they send out their product to multiple universities to do a study if
seven of them come back say no this is this is a carcinogen and one of them comes back oh we found
it to be safe that's the only one that they publish yeah the rest of the studies are tossed in a bin
probably shredded and they publish the one that they want to publish at the publication bias they have
full legal rights to do that so you don't find out about what is really dangerous because it's never
it's never published so you do have to just you know listeners please listen to what Brian say
you read the ingredients on the back of your thing you should not be consuming it so yeah that is a
great point about the studies beyond that what are they studying they they're not really studying
you know long-term impacts they're they're typically in almost all cases like I mentioned not studying
the effect of multiple of these toxic synthetic ingredients in combination with one another they
won't they're studying in isolation and in a short term the effect of these ingredients
had a mouse model or something like that in a mouse model short-term effect not in combination with
all the other jump that they throw in these typical products so you know these have been independently
studying and and all I will say to people is big caution now again 1300 chemicals banned elsewhere
in the European Union and elsewhere for 40 different countries actually only 11 here so then I get
that question well what should we watch out for again that's 1300 chemicals is mighty hard to try
to verse I'm not worse nobody's versed on all of these chemicals to watch out for on labels there are
some more common ones formaldehyde comes to mind you know I mean this is the same stuff that back
in biology class you were preserving frogs with this is common commonly found in many different types
of cosmetics something you really don't want to be putting on your body it's you know it is
potential it you know carcinogen you know for sure um trickle son and another one people might
remember in 2016 this was banned from antibacterial hands so so guess what what's odd is so it's banned
antibacterial hands soaps because obviously it was found to be dangerous enough but it's allowed
in anti-aging skin products and everything else still like wait a minute that doesn't even make
sense you know it's the power of the industry on this it truly is buyer beware and you have to take
control of your own health and this is such an unknown topic you know again to people about how
impactful this can be with with the industry yes they they are aware let's in my opinion okay I
I'll preface it that way and I think everyone's gonna agree they are well aware of the risks of
this stuff of course they are watching out for short term negative effects because if they put
a product out and it has a short term negative effect it can easily be traced to them they don't want
to do that they want to sell their stuff but they listen I I'm putting it in my words my view they
don't care about you know somewhat longer effects mid-term effects certainly not long-term effects
of what happens they use these synthetic ingredients because well in a word they're cheap and they
mean it's easier to sell more products these ingredients are added to sell more stuff sit on the
shelves longer penetrate deeper into your body which is scary when you think about it the penetrators
are one of the scariest classes of these ingredients that pull other toxins deeper into your body like
you had already alluded to you know it's just scary what what they're doing with this and if
doctor I say this I listen yes okay so if there's this minute amount of this ingredient in these products
and I know it and I was going to use deodorant one day in my life I'd be like okay it's such a
minute amount I don't care I'll use this but we use deodorant every day along here's a statistic the
average woman uses 12 personal care products a day which contain an average of 168 different chemicals
now add that up day after day week after week month after month year after year it's kind of like
death by a thousand cuts it's going to have a negative effect on you if you're using these typical
products with all these synthetic ingredients it's cumulative yeah and you mentioned that
by aging things and somebody listening might say well I don't use any of that I think in the
lotions the sunscreen the makeup that people are using the anything that they're putting on their skin
thinking that it's going to be a protective or a moisturizer like you gave a statistic a how many
care products that women put on their skin very more particularly exposed than most men but now
you have a beard there's beard oil things and there's all sorts of hair products and shampoo that
people are using it's perfumes we use go on and on these are just all just chemical slurries that
your liver is going literally if you can make it a cartoon of it like what in the same heck are you
doing to me I can't deal with all this stuff that you're exposing me to so now let me the kind of
so people you know I hate giving issues and problems you know without without giving people general
guidelines at least on solutions because you know when you do talk about things like moisturizers creams
anti-aging creams deodorants of course anything people what am I supposed to do what am I supposed to do
you know we're so you know attached to these and in some cases it makes sense and there are products
up there that can help so real quick before on what we're supposed to do what what you what you
really want to do is take inventory of what you are using on a routine basis and my you know kind
of Brian's law as we'll call is the more you're putting the closer you're putting it onto your skin
and the more you're using it the more concern you should be about it so a deodorant I keep bringing that
up because it's under your arm all day every single day in this very sensitive you know part of your
body where the skin you know and so that's an important one if you do use creams moisturizers anything
on your face around your eyes it's very sensitive skin be very wary of those you should be wary of
all the products but a shampoo you use you know what what you wash your hair you know every other day
or three days a week or once a week whatever if I'm if I'm ranking these I'd say yeah you cautious
that too but the ones you're they're sitting on your body designed to penetrate all day long be
especially where those take inventory in your home of these of these products and it as as as
really powerful health promoting changes go it's a pretty easy change to make and I'm talking in
comparison to you know someone who hasn't moved much in a long time and then has to get exercise or
someone who has to completely shift their diet those are super important those are harder to do just
to put it in layman's terms this is pretty easy and it can have monumental impacts on your health
including the way you feel so that is the solution in general it's really tough as I've noted
to try to verse yourself on all the potential chemicals to look out for because people have turned
these products around and it's hard to decipher what happens these things are sometimes instead I say
there are some really good guideline independent certifications out there to look for in the United
States look for USDA certified organic products that means that means in the US it's not the only one
but it's it's a it's a great one to look for on the front of the label USDA certified because that
means those products unless unless the companies scamming people and putting that label on and they
shouldn't be in which case they can get sued but that means those products have gone through
independent of the company you know a strict certification doing sure that at least 95% of those
ingredients are indeed organic and toxin free and then it's a short list of other that other 5% are
also very particular ingredients that are not going to hurt you so that's that's one guideline in
other countries if you have listeners here from elsewhere there are in most countries that I'm
aware they have similar guidelines echo cert which is based out of France and covers a lot of
Europe and and elsewhere in the world is another one and then there are some states also in the United
States that have strict certifications really look for those certifications support them they're not
for profit whether they're government sponsored or independent nonprofit organizations you know everyone
many people have probably seen the non GMO thing and watch for those on the front of the label because
unless the company scamming you and they're not supposed to be putting those on those are independently
granted and they have to go through steps it's a it's a it's a strong way to choose products that are
far less to flat out zero toxins that you can and then we've come a long way we being a general
sense you know 10 years ago there was a few organic deodorants and and frankly are terrible now we're
a little further along and I you know I use you know these these products and they're pretty darn good
now and they do the job for example with the odorants anti-aging creams I mean more and more you're seeing
these products out there it's kind of like food you know 10 15 years ago where people were really
just learning about how you know how bad certain types of food could be and all the organic stuff
started and all of them you know really started and I know it's been around forever and now it's
gotten better and better you know some of these food products what's this we're about 10 years behind
with with cosmetics and personal care products but I would advocate people look for that USDA certified
organic and other certifications the more the barrier will that be on makeups and other things too
so cosmetics yes yes makeups the hardest category in my opinion you're starting to see some
USDA certified organic you know labels out there but you will see it on creams and anti-aging creams
more and more now it's a little easier to find and you certainly will see it on toothpaste you will
certainly see it on many deodorants now in fact in your big box stores you know they're moving
over and you'll see it for sure deodorants and things like that so just you know you can Google
search USDA certified organic skin cream or anti-aging cream deodorants you know EWG the environmental
working group they have a list of products in these different categories as well but again simple
Google search you'll see it's it's a it's a blossoming and thank goodness area where there's
conscious companies well aware of this truly taking steps to improve this be careful one more one
do be careful of what's called green washing don't listen to what a company says about itself
to put it flatly if they call themselves all natural or organic or you know wildcrafted that can
mean anything again it's it's you know perhaps the most unregulated industry out there organic can
mean once if they're calling themselves organic if you mean that they're one single organic ingredient
amidst 25 synthetics and they could say organic on the label that's just messing with people look
for those independent certifications like USDA certified organic that's great yeah we we we can't
finish today's podcast without talking about your summit okay so let's jump into that now so how
people can learn more about this topic and a lot of other topics greatly so with other speakers
that have specialties in different areas so give us some information about your summit coming up
well thanks this is the big one so again as as you noted I've hosted multiple of these big free
online summits where again because I've been at this 20 some years I've had the honor of getting
in all folks like yourself and and other very well-known highly acclaimed doctors who embrace
integrative and natural health approaches de-nournerish tactical firm and many and and so in my case
you know I'm the communicator the intermediary and also now I guess because I've acquired so much
knowledge over these years myself sometimes the educator as well but you know it's my honor to be
able to bring as people will see with younger longer the insider's health summit 22 of the true
really really you know brilliant wonderful and caring which is always important to me you know
doctors and other health experts who kind of at the forefront of anti-aging in a in a healthy way
or healthy aging and longevity and avoiding and overcoming disease you know cancer and heart disease
and other travel diseases of our time so I've pulled them all together and what I saw out there
being at this for years the one you asked me about a big problem one big big problem that I see people
encounter is an overwhelm of information there is so much health and wellness information out there
now granted a lot of it seems to be the same you know the things repeated over and over but there's
such an overwhelming amount and I said okay you know what I want to help people in a big way with
this particular summit which is why I call it the big one I'm clearly air and what I do in this
event younger longer is I ask the doctors this key question from your area of expertise doctor
what are the three most essential things people must do to look and feel their best avoid and
overcome disease and live long doing it let's clear the air from your area of expertise you know
whether you're a dietary expert whether your expertise is in sleep you know and I pull all the
different you know angles in on these experts I'm bringing in give me the three things that are
most important that people can do themselves out of everything so I clear the air bone we hit
straight to the heart of the matter in this event so it's a supremely useful event you know for
people practical useful clear the air and all this overwhelm and confusion and get right to the key key
points well you need to have those bullet points because it does get overwhelming for people
our bullet points for this presentation have been to start reading your labels maybe be more conscious
particularly conscious about what you're putting on your skin is you're putting it your
liver is going to have to deal with this stuff you are absorbing what you put on your skin
and just start it's not that difficult like you said it's just start
buying different products and even if you live in podunk you know USA there is organic things that
you can purchase you can order them online that you can make different purchasing choices and then
that strength like you said that strengthens the industry these companies continue to produce better
in better products that work more effectively in personal care as well so it's not really that
difficult you're buying these things anyhow yes you may pay a few extra dollars for a good organic
product but you're it's gonna it's gonna affect you in so many ways you talk about not just cancer
but the onset of early dementia in this country is just staggering and it has to do with chemicals
anterior to crossing the blood braid barrier and your microglial cells activated because of that
but it's so those are the key points I think maybe you have anything to add to that
the one thing I'll say is you know so look for those certifications like I mentioned and don't
I'll put it this way don't be surprised if you have mystery symptoms a lot of people don't know
where my fatigue comes from I'm not sure or if you have dizziness or if you have shortness of breath
I'll just say don't be surprised if you do take these steps to reduce the toxins even in this one
very key area with with products that you feed in your skin and you do shift over and feed your
body far healthier choices don't be surprised if those symptoms diminish maybe in some cases disappear
I've seen it time and again because again your body's overwhelmed with toxins this is one of the
key ways they're overwhelmed when you reduce that the body likes that the body says thank you
thanks for feeding me these products instead that have you know natural safe organic ingredients that
are actually good for me instead of products that contain hydroquinone and thalates and like I mentioned
trickle sign in front thank you thank you for doing that and these symptoms may in fact reduce
not to mention the fact that you're far less you know you're you're reducing your fighting disease
if you have it and you're reducing the likelihood of getting disease if you don't in a big way like
you mentioned whether it is brain diseases and then you're you know the gender issues heart
cancer so many so many obviously connected I mean pretty much often really want to expand it out
to to overwhelm your bodies with toxins reduce it this is a big way you're going to be pleased with
how you feel relatively quickly as well as the longer term results. Well Brian thank you again we're
going to have all sorts of information about your website and the coming summit we're going to
encourage all our listeners to participate in that and if you're listening to this recorded
years later you can download that information on Brian's website as well. We're going to have
you back again I hope to talk about more things or so many things to speak about so I appreciate it
again this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we'll be back with another podcast thanks